usually only rifle clubs practice in
Gotland tough to forest and this World
War 2 era cannon has certainly seen
better days but this fake building is a
sign that Sweden is holding its largest
maneuvering decades patrick Menards 18th
battalion was transferred to Gotland
following Russia's Crimea annexation now
we're doing the right thing
the national defense in the way did it
feels good to be here again four tanks
were moved to Gotland from the mainland
they're not state-of-the-art it's
evident that Sweden hasn't been involved
in Wars for a while the soldiers are new
recruits with lots to learn the Swedish
company is pretty new they started their
service in in June this year so we have
a little bit to do before we get where
we want to be since Russia began
redrawing European borders fears of a
surprise attack on Sweden have been
growing Gatlin could be a target
but the Swedes worried they couldn't
defend it alone which is why they've
called on American support now for the
first time American Apache attack
helicopters are thundering over the
island practicing attack sorties a
Swedish tank crews practice their aim
Sweden always prefer to remain a neutral
state and so Sweden's officers don't
mention Russia at the drill instead they
simply talk of Reds versus blues also be
a red side played by another switch unit
and some Finnish units and also some
it's just the colours yeah typically
that's how it was in the military
setting is red versus blue there's a
backstory to this drill one that shows
how worried the Swedes are we're headed
to the poor eastern part of Gotland it's
a quiet region with few jobs and much
debt many are moving away we're in the
harbour town of Sleater there's a cement
factory and little else they used to
keep pipes here for the German rush and
Nordstrom to gas pipeline now there's
just a pile of logs
Sweden's government was worried Russia
could establish a secret military base
here you call this Putin key yes but we
used to call it pharmacist key that's
where Nordstrom stored pipes for the
first pipeline every week we get a
Russian ship transporting coal plaster
or cement keeping the pipes here wasn't
an issue why should it be an issue now
why can't we store pipes for naught
Salim to here I don't get it some of the
people of Sleater missed out on 50
million kroners roughly 5 million euro
worth of business a new storage site is
now being constructed in Carl's harm on
the mainland
due to their long tradition of trading
with Russia few people in Sleater are
worried about their large eastern
neighbor the Russians wanted a conquered
goblin they could do so any time they
don't need our harbor for that after the
three-day drill several hundred soldiers
remain on the island too few thinks
Patrick Minard military officers like
him are suspicious of the Russians they
think who controls Gotland controls the
Baltic I want to know if the soldiers
left here will be enough as a defense
army can we be enough soldiers I don't
know a reasonable consideration but an
unusual one for a Swede after all the
country hasn't fought a war in over 200
years